The right choice is the design priorities of
Mach. First of all, I already mentioned that the
number that I showed you for Mach's performance
for user to kernel switch, is on the same
processing hardware as L3 uses, and therefore there
is no cheating here, and the Liedtke may be
smaller but that's not the reason either. And
it is not because microkernels are slow by definition,
but it is because of the fact that the design priorities of Mach was
different. And in particular, Mach's design priority
was not just extensibility of an operating
system, but also portability. And we will
talk more about how that portability design
consideration comes into play. In the performance
of an operating system later on. But at
this point I just want you to understand that the
reason why Mach took significantly more time for this border crossing
compared to L3 micro kernel. Is nothing to do with the
structure of the micro kernel. It is only the design priorities.